um
i'll go ahead
this is kind of funny airlines won't fly
home quebec passengers from sun wing
party flight to mexico
sun wing what the [__] airline is that
random good
can't be good dude
sounds made sun wing
sounds mid as hell passengers who filmed
themselves partying masculists aboard a
chartered sunwing airlines flight from
montreal to mexico last week have become
pariahs and now face being stranded
after two more airlines announced
wednesday they will not fly them home to
canada
wow
following sunwing's cancellation of the
return charter flight where they
chartered a jet
and now they can't is what
honestly mexico not a bad place to be
stuck
yeah
can't go wrong on the airlines man you
saw that you saw a lady that spit on
that dude because he took his mask down
he was eating and now she's like facing
assault charges wait what what happened
yeah there's this crazy karen video this
woman was batshit
old man pulled his mask down it was one
of those you know
he's just one of those guys that's just
like
he's old
and
here's what's funny to me when you tell
an old person like put their mask on bro
you get i imagine when you're older you
get on like to a certain side of the
scale where you're like
[__] if i go on this plane
i don't give a [__]
you know
yeah
like i i'll you know i live through like
i lived through world war ii
yeah i i would see martin luther king on
the tv like i'm old man like yeah
this guy wasn't that old i think it
probably is like in his 50s but he's old
enough where it's just like that's not
old oh yeah it's not old that's not old
but i just feel like 50s you're kind of
like
yeah okay if it happens like it happens
right okay
like if i get it i get it kind of yeah i
imagine like if you're older that's kind
of like that's got to be your vibe you
know yeah
you've ducked a lot of things you me you
ducked the draft you
you know whatever
yeah survive ronald reagan whatever like
i just feel like you're desensitized to
certain amounts of threat
so i just feel like what that boils down
to is like there's some people that pull
it down they leave it like on the bottom
of their lip and they're like right take
a sip of water and like they push it
back up yeah i mean it's just old so he
just took it off one ear
okay and then he was hanging yeah
it's fine and the lady's like barking at
him and he's like i'm i'm drinking water
i'm i'm eating i can take my mask off
when i'm eating like she's just not
accepting that this is an old man
he's just gonna eat that [__] packet
of pretzels and put that [__] back on
and shut the [__] up right so then she's
just like put your [__] mask on
and he just started he's like yo he's
like get out of my face you karen [__]
you [__] karen
nice
and then she's and she spits on him
jesus
oh my god the irony in that yeah the
irony yeah
of someone getting so mad about a mask
not being on and then spitting in his
face
yeah that's so funny what a hypocrite
yeah what a [__] right i think jesus
christ
and then yeah so now uh
she's facing charges dumbass dude
jesus
i want to see that
look it up we got time
karen plain spit
video shows weird why are all the
results pornhub
yeah what is this karen spitz on wow
weird
um pov karen spits in your mouth what
karen caught on video slapping passenger
in delta flight tirade
oh she hit him first too yeah yeah punch
and spit
oh my god
oh this guy's old as [__] man this guy's
like 70 probably
it's okay see i was i was off she
punched him in the [__] face yeah
yeah
weirdo man
oh my god okay so so if you're spitting
in someone's face then you clearly don't
care that much about covid no so at that
point you're a loser because you're just
like reinforcing a rule that's not even
yours yeah you know what i'm saying yeah
you're a nerd
you're a nerd you're a boss you got to
put the the airline says you got to put
the mask on
sunwing
i'm
i'm on sunwing's side
listen to delta do what delta says do
what delta says delta is awesome
put on the there she is right there
there she is right there
yeah
she's not even [__] wearing it yeah
that's the iron the [__]
she's screaming at him with her mask
down
i don't understand straight dummy man
so play it yeah let it play we're
learning more about the woman at the
center of that disturbing clash on a
planet
patricia cornwall was arrested for
allegedly hitting and spitting on a 69
year old man
[Applause]
69 a winner who is she cornwall now
works as a realtor but she used to be a
raider at cheerleader she's also a
former actress who appeared on married
with children and baywatch under the
name patti breton you won the bikini
contest in palm springs last year the
criminal complaint obtained by inside
edition says the clash started when
cornwall was returning from the bathroom
and found the beverage cart blocking the
aisle the flight attendant asked
cornwall to find an open seat until
beverage service was complete
cornwall and elderly passenger russell
miller then go at it over masks
when he calls her a rude name
oh my god
the police report says miller had
visible injury
i don't have any injuries his face and
head area
now you're double going to jail
eventually the delta flight attendants
managed to pull her away oh you cut it
off
jesus christ damn should i baywatch
money
she was an actress she was
all these things yeah bro she um
i mean i just
maybe i don't know what do you got to be
going through to really get that mad
yeah that's the craziest thing she
wasn't even wearing her mask so what are
you mad about
now
she okay
apparently she
apparently she's had
brushes with the law i guess she had
like a dui or something
she tried to fight the cops in florida
up she's in florida
okay it's not her fault she's living in
grand theft auto
[Laughter]
she's living in a gta server it's not
it's not her fault
she didn't realize she's not like
in the headset you know
poor girl honestly yeah she's just
solving problems the florida way on an
airplane and she didn't realize that's a
that's a lower level server she crashed
her truck into a tree and then tried to
fight the cops that is hardcore
sick sounds like a good chick
there's some there's some dudes
listening to this [__] right now like
she sounds [__] nuts she sounds hot
what's up
what's her at
where's her at though what's her at
crazy let her slap me dude
yeah she's just getting spin my face
just spit on my
legs bruh
no means a [__] man
pinocchio
you